leur masse et déjà c'est sait
comme dirait 0t n'est ce pas un poil ou
à la
nature si on avait quelque chose qui
dérangeait l'espace est plus ou moins
n'aime pas le voit salle
[Musique]
il
c'est une manière pour moi de lui des
pointes d'or à la pollution mais dit que
les déchets que l'homme du raisin lola
mais n'avait pas la nationale a donc là
mais nous ramène voilà donc moi allez
les bronzes de la aux données
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or sur la thématique
de la causerie 19 ans et c'est ce qui
fait actuellement c'est ce qui fait
l'actualité voilà et moi en tant
qu'artiste
je me considère comme témoins de deux
montants de mon époque voilà pourquoi
j'ai réalisé cet hymne
en venant grave et qui est un travail
d'ailleurs très délicat et très
difficile des profits sur ses tongs
c'est comme si de retrouver les
propriétaires et donc il retrace une
histoire et l'ensemble de ces tombes
associer des unes aux autres
c'est notre monde c'est ce monde là et
j'ai aimé voilà sept cette démarche là
cette application à la fois écologiques
mais aussi tous ceux toute cette
démarche artistique
[Musique]